I'm gonna say that it wasn't a lack of
Courage from Bernie it was actual fear
well maybe that is a lack of Courage but
he was afraid of Donald Trump he was
like if I stay in the race as an
independent Trump's going to win if in
my opinion we're at the you actually
were talking about late stage Empire
repeatedly before the show started we're
at that phase where if you're interested
in salvaging this country the
Constitution civilization or culture
whatever and you want to get involved in
politics you have to be willing to give
up everything you have to just go in
there fearlessly doing the right thing
because you know there's something
bigger than yourself let's talk about
that let me let me finish that thought
that's what they do they dangle the
carrot they give you some money they
give you the option to write a
best-selling book and that's how they
keep you complacent why would you want
to sacrifice that comfort